we had no idea how Tesla would change
our lives I wear a lot of hats by I'm a
producer for commercials I am a mom in
the beginning we just had one car and we
would fight over who got to drive it so
the rule was whoever was driving the
furthest would get the Tesla and now
we've added a Model X to our family
[Music]
we're a very busy family so we have to
travel a lot every day Paige drives a
lot we never know exactly where she's
going
I use my Model X like my office I do a
lot of conference calls autopilot lets
me do that when it's bumper-to-bumper I
can put on autopilot and know that we're
gonna be safe charging has never been a
problem
Todd likens it to charging your cell
phone when you get home at night you
plug in your cell phone that's how we do
it with our cars
I don't think that there's another car
out there that gets better the longer
you own it the performance is amazing
technology is amazing that's a huge
testament to what's important to me for
my family that's why we like Tesla's
because they keep up with us and I love
that
I'm Paige and my family is an electric
family
[Music]